y deportados a Corea del Norte,
donde son torturados, encarcelados
o ejecutados en público.
Aunque fui afortunada en escapar,
muchos otros norcoreanos no han tenido tanta suerte.
Es trágico que los norcoreanos tengan que ocultar sus identidades
y luchar tan duro solo para sobrevivir.
Incluso después de aprender un nuevo idioma y encontrar trabajo,
todo su mundo puede tumbarse en un instante.
Es por eso que, después de 10 años de ocultar mi identidad,
he decidí arriesgarme yendo a Corea del Sur
y comencé una nueva vida otra vez.
Asentarme en Corea del Sur fue un reto mucho
mayor de lo que esperaba.
El inglés era muy importante en Corea del Sur,
tuve que comenzar a aprender mi tercer idioma.
También, comprendí que había una gran brecha
entre Norte y Sur.
Somos todos coreanos, pero por dentro,
hemos llegado a ser muy diferentes
debido a 67 años de división.
Incluso atravesé una crisis de identidad.
¿Soy surcoreana o norcoreana?
¿De dónde soy? ¿Quién soy?
De pronto, no había un país
que pudiera llamar con orgullo mío.
Aunque adaptarme a la vida en Corea del Sur no fue fácil,
hice un plan.
Comencé a estudiar para el examen de ingreso a la Universidad.
Justo cuando comenzaba a adaptarme a mi nueva vida,
recibí una llamada alarmante.
Las autoridades de Corea del Norte
interceptaron algo de dinero que envié a mi familia,
y, como castigo, mi familia iba a ser
desplazada a la fuerza
a una ubicación alejada en las afueras.
Tenían que huir de inmediato
asi comencé a planear cómo ayudarlos a escapar.
Los norcoreanos tienen que viajar largas distancias
en el camino hacia la libertad.
Es casi imposible cruzar la frontera
entre Corea del Norte y Corea del Sur,
Asi que, irónicamente, tomé un vuelo a China
y me encaminé hacia la frontera con Corea del Norte.
Ya que mi familia no podía hablar chino,
tuve que guiarlos,
de alguna manera, por más de 3 mil km a través de China
y entonces a través del sudeste de Asia.
El viaje en autobus tomó una semana,
y casi fuimos atrapados varias veces.
Una vez, nuestro autobús fue detenido
y abordado por un oficial de la policía chino.
Pidió la identificación de todos.
y comenzó a hacerles preguntas.
Como mi familia no podía comprender chino,
pensé que mi familia iba a ser arrestada.
Cuando el oficial chino se acercó a mi familia,
impulsivamente me puse de pie y le dije
que eran personas sordomudas
que estaba acompañando.
Me miró sospechosamente
pero afortunadamente me creyó.
Hicimos todo el camino hasta la frontera de Laos,
pero tuve que gastar casi todo mi dinero
para sobornar a los guardias fronterizos en Laos.
Pero incluso después de pasar la frontera,
mi familia fue arrestada y encarcelada
por cruzar la frontera ilegalmente.
Después de pagar multas y sobornos,
mi familia fue liberada en un mes,
pero al tiempo, mi familia fue arrestada y encarcelada otra vez
en la capital de Laos.
Este fue uno de los puntos más bajos en mi vida,
hice todo por liberar a mi familia,
y estuvimos tan cerca,
pero mi familia fue retenida en prisión
a corta distancia de la embajada de Corea del Sur.
Yo iba y venía entre la oficina de inmigración
y la estación de policía,
desesperadamente tratando de liberar a mi familia,
pero no tenía suficiente dinero
para pagar más sobornos o multas.
Perdí la esperanza.
En ese momento, oí la voz de un hombre preguntarme,
"¿Cuál es el problema?"
Yo estaba tan sorprendida
que un desconocido le importara preguntar.
Con mi pobre inglés y con un diccionario,
le expliqué la situación, y sin dudar,
el hombre fue al cajero automático
y me dio el resto del dinero para mi familia
y para otros dos norcoreanos y sacarlos de prisión.
Le agradecí con todo mi corazón, y le pregunté,
"¿Por qué me ayuda?"
"No te estoy ayudando", me dijo.
"Estoy ayudando al pueblo norcoreano".
Me di cuenta que ese era un momento simbólico en mi vida.
El amable desconocido simbolizó una nueva esperanza para mí
y para el pueblo norcoreano cuando más lo necesitábamos,
y me mostró que la bondad de los desconocidos
y el apoyo de la comunidad internacional
son realmente los rayos de esperanza que el pueblo norcoreano necesita.
Con el tiempo, después de nuestro largo viaje,
mi familia y yo nos reunimos en Corea del Sur,
pero lograr su libertad es solo la mitad de la batalla.
Muchos norcoreanos son separados de sus familias
y cuando arriban a un nuevo país,
ellos comienzan con poco o nada de dinero.
Por lo tanto, podemos beneficiarnos de la comunidad internacional
con educación, prácticas del idioma inglés,
prácticas de trabajo, y más.
Podemos también actuar como puente
entre personas dentro de Corea del Norte
y el resto del mundo,
porque muchos de nosotros seguimos en contacto
con familiares todavía adentro,
y mandamos información y dinero
que está ayudando a cambiar Corea del Norte desde adentro.
He sido muy afortunada, he recibido mucha ayuda
e inspiración en mi vida,
por eso quiero ayudar dando a norcoreanos
una oportunidad de prosperar
con apoyo internacional.
Estoy segura que van a ver más y más
norcoreanos triunfando en todo el mundo,
incluyendo en el escenario de TED.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)